merry christmas
is this for real you know what to do
press until it hurts
wire transfer from your account to
joanna webster's
phone records with joanna webster prior
to her testimony
in an affidavit stating you paid miss
webster to falsely testify
mr hunt harassment is a civil violation
the penalty is money but
witness tampering that's a crime and you
will go to prison where
i guarantee you'll learn more about
unwanted sexual advances that you can
possibly
imagine do you think this is going to
intimidate me
even if this evidence was credible who
are you going to get to prosecute a
small-time witness tampering charge huh
harvey didn't you graduate law school
with the
current u.s attorney in new york in fact
i did
and i think he might even be interested
in pursuing a case like this wait are
you two still close
well i was the best man in his wedding
wow there you weren't
you're bluffing no i think i've got some
pictures
of us at the ceremony let's see
yeah here we are must admit i
i look very dashing this is me and his
mother a woman adores me
here we are at his bachelor party
there's no strippers
he's lame but he can't put guys like you
away for sexual harassment then go to
strip clubs now can he
all right what do you want an admission
of guilt
and a guarantee that you'll obtain
treatment before working again
and nancy gets reinstated with back pay
fine and a raise oh okay all right
are we done the kid should be able to
grow up without the burden of tuition
hanging over his head don't you think
which is why you're also gonna pay nancy
an extra 250 000
charles
gentlemen okay so this was all some sort
of test
you blackmail me you jeopardize my job
stop we all came out ahead didn't we
that new client's gonna bring us
millions
jessica knows your name now it's a win
win
you're right she does know my name
which is why she'll listen when i tell
her exactly what happened
okay but before you do that it is
that time again isn't it what time
peanut cup time
and now you know i'd fail of course you
can run to mommy tell your story and
take your chances
or you can take the test and trust that
i'll keep it to myself
as my way of thanking you
uh you know i actually did some reading
of the uh pearson hardman drug policy as
well
turns out that you have to wait three
months before you can request another
drug test
so it's a little detail you might have
missed so drink up
oh and uh i spoke to tom keller he says
that he feels he'd be best served with
the combination of me and harvey
i think you'll get that call in the
morning mr ross the truth is i don't
remember where the james jenkins pitch
came from
then it could have come from myra well
he could have but it doesn't matter even
if i had stolen it she signed the
employee agreement which gives drecker
publishing the rights to her work
product yes i know
well then you also know i'm not going to
taint my company's reputation by giving
myra credit
i'm not asking you to give her credit
i'm asking you to give her compensation
in exchange for a confidential
settlement agreement which protects your
reputation
that sounds like blackmail
respectman this lawsuit is the only
thing holding up a billion dollar merger
and every day that it drags on it's
costing your company more money
what i'm talking about is giving myra
harrison a crumb
of a crumb so stop worrying about what
it sounds like and start writing a check
how much is the gonna cost that's what i
want to hear
i represent tony zelinski you can't talk
to me without my lawyer
oh you're right i can't go ahead and
turn me in when you do
i'll tell them all about zalinski's
source inside your clubhouse [ __ ]
baseball's a brotherhood nobody in my
team would go public against me
rugen hernandez isn't on your team
anymore
reuben tries ratting out a former
teammate no ball club in this league
will forgive him he might not have a
choice
when we subpoena him no no way
zelinski's giving up ruben he'd have
done it already
you might not but i will
you're in a rundown roberto drop the
suit and announce your retirement from
baseball you out of your mind
you do it zelinski will never mention
your name on air again
you don't hernandez outs you and the
whole world knows who you are
this ends here the two of you have now
slandered me which violates the morality
clause
of the partner's agreement it's not
slander if it's the truth unfortunately
you don't have a shred of evidence
because the evidence doesn't exist
actually it does
this is a partners only meeting so have
tanner sue me but in the meantime
i think the rest of the partners are
going to want to see this it's a signed
affidavit from lawrence kemp
stating that he told daniel hartman
about the defects in the cm hood six
years ago
may 7th was the date of that meeting per
your calendar to be exact
you just denied knowing anything about
that unequivocally
i guess you were just lying to cover up
the fact that you're behind this entire
suit
in the first place is that
the basis of this a coerced lie from a
man
trying to say my lawyer made me do it
no way that holds up in court doesn't
have to
just has to make these harvard educated
lawyers understand
that you made each and every one of them
spend a hundred thousand dollars of
their own money
to buy you control of my firm i think
we've heard all we needed to hear
harvey has admitted to violating the
drug policy
all those in favor of his dismissal
looks like you lost i'm glad you brought
up the bylaws
fraudulently suing your own firm is
grounds for firing
you have no proof of that all those in
favor of daniel hardman's dismissal
hey harvey i know i'm not a partner but
you modified go ahead nice
dr lombard on december 7 2006 did a
patient die on your table during a
routine angioplasty
objection your honor relevance it speaks
to its qualifications as an expert
witness your honor
island now yes a patient died
and was a malpractice suit filed against
you for physician error that case was
sealed i didn't ask you if it was sealed
i asked if it was filed
it was and settled for almost nothing
objection your honor move to strike the
case is sealed
the witness isn't allowed to testify to
the details of that settlement sustained
have you practiced medicine since yes
i've been practicing
i'm sorry what i meant to say is have
you performed surgery the job you spent
seven years training to do
no what loss of confidence they wouldn't
let you
objections speculation i want to answer
to my question
i chose to do other things other things
that don't involve the chance of you
killing people
objection withdrawn what's your primary
source of income
i work as an expert witness so you
testify now to make a living because you
don't trust yourself to do the job that
you were trained to do
i can speak to the facts of this case
yes you can speak to them but how are we
supposed to trust your opinion about
them when you clearly don't trust
yourself
this is bigger than i expected yeah i've
heard that before
okay fun time's over i'm not interested
in selling to someone who i don't know
where they're coming from
let me tell you where i'm coming from i
do my homework
these centers are a beacon to every
predator out there that you haven't laid
the groundwork to get out of the dvd
business
sounds to me like where you're coming
from it's trying to scare me no no i'm
not trying to scare you i'm trying to
help you
they're circling and you know it you
don't do this
you might as well send out an invitation
asking for a hostile takeover
this number can't be real it is then
what the hell are you going to do with
my distribution centers i'll be happy to
tell you that five seconds after i buy
them
walter i know you want your people to be
okay and i give you my word they will be
but these centers
they become a headache and you need cash
for when those predators come knocking
let them knock i'm not answering the
door no
you're not hearing me if you don't raise
enough money
they're coming in whether you answer
that door or not
you told me that i can think of this
office as a reminder of what i did to
harvey or as a symbol of what i can do
with this firm
but the thing is i don't want to be here
if i'm not
solid with harvey well that's between
you and harvey
it's between you and me
you put yourself between us when you
blackmailed me
well the word you're looking for is
extortion not blackmail
and i'm not going to comment on that
accusation but as for
your choices you made those all by
yourself
so don't come crying to me
this is a copy of the letter you wrote
to the district attorney when you
threatened to expose me expose you for
what
i never wrote a letter like that i'm not
recording you
i don't need to record you this letter
was printed from your hard drive which
has your computer's digital signature
[Music]
what do you want i want to know if you
had the chance would you have traded
that car to get your parents back
together
it's a stupid goddamn question you know
it
i never had that chance so what does it
matter because i do
what do i want
i want to give this office back
i didn't earn it i don't want it and if
there's a chance it'll help harvey
forgive me
i'm gonna take it
oh and uh if you ever do
send that letter you're in the same boat
as me
[Music]
you